[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 23
novembre
le plasticien hugo verlinde vous
entraîne dans l'espace son espace où les
mets des mathématiques et l'art se
mélange il expose à la commanderie des
templiers au musée lambiner les femmes
sont à l'honneur celles qui ont fait la
révolution française à travers des
tableaux d'époque le public découvre
redécouvrez personnalité de cette
période et nous partirons à la rencontre
d'une compagnie théâtrale amateur la
troupe en chantier elle joue depuis deux
ans sur dans les salles francilienne
cette année saint quentin en yvelines
mise sur le futur l'espace et la
conquête spatiale
de nombreuses expositions seront
proposées et les premières ont déjà élu
domicile à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt c'est l'infini intime du
goût vers l'inde
elle vous prouve que l'art et les matic
les mathématiques peuvent faire un tout
les images sont signés camille lambert
allergique aux mathématiques ne fuyait
pas c'est derviches sont des croquis la
base du travail de vos vers l'inde
le plasticien français on fait de l'art
de laruns numérique
c'est une passion c'est j'ai commencé
sans même imaginer que j'étais dans une
démarche artistique
j'avais vraiment
hacker une recherche le désir de
découvrir ou de mener ce matériau
[Musique]
fascination pour les courbes depuis
l'enfance donc géorgie je vois de
l'infini dans l'écho simule les sinus et
l'obérythmée les exponentielle et j'ai
commencé vraiment très tôt a commencé à
combiner c'est ce matériau des oeuvres
infini à la vie autonome
hugo verlinde de créer des codes
permettant de développer des univers
propre comme ceux lotus réalisé en lycra
exposé pour la première fois
[Musique]
c'est un rêve c'est un rêve le point de
départ du lotus c'est je me suis vu dans
une pièce un peu comme ici une grande
pièce beaucoup d'espacé des auteurs et
en me baladant j'étais face à un énorme
pétales exactement donc cette forme
qu'on voit là et j'en faisais le tour et
je découvrais une projection sur sur un
pétale jeux de lumière les sensations
des espaces infinis hugo verlinde vous
entraîne dans un voyage numérique
condorcet robespierre danton mara ses
hommes ont tous un point commun ils ont
marqué la révolution française de 1789
que des hommes aucune femme et pourtant
elles ont aussi compté durant cette
période
le musée lambinet de versailles a choisi
de leur consacrer une exposition un
premier aperçu avec les images de
patrick jacques de dixmude rendre
justice aux femmes victimes de la
révolution mais aussi actrice sur le
terrain politique par la violence
parfois théroigne de méricourt a pris
les armes olympe de gouges rédige une
déclaration des droits de la femme et de
la citoyenne
elles sont également
dans un moment où la violence qu'elle
revendique va permettre précisément de
les évacuer assez rapidement de la
sphère politique au motif de leur
dangerosité supposée au motif de leur
caractère passionné qui est rendu
responsable d'un certain nombre d'excès
de la révolution française ce qui est
d'autant plus paradoxale qu'elles sont
en fait les victimes privilégiées en
mars 1789 les femmes marchent sur
versailles à travers des peintures
l'exposition retrace leur histoire
jusqu'au début du 21e siècle
trois salles sont consacrées à charlotte
corday le musée possédant la plus grande
collection mondiale d'oeuvre à son
propos elle est intéressante puisqu'elle
a une double mémoire c'est d'abord pour
certains l'héroïne qui a sauvé le peuple
de mara le sanguinaire donc ça c'est
plutôt l'historiographie d'une tradition
réactionnaire qui est sa et d'insister
sur les méfaits de la révolution et puis
elle est également pour un autre courant
plutôt républicain l'ennemi public celle
qui a attenté au jour de l'ami du peuple
celle qui a donc voulu combattre le
processus révolutionnaire issues de
collections privées et local les oeuvres
exposées sont pour la plupart inédites
pour se plonger dans deux siècles et
2000 d'imaginaire de la violence et des
femmes sous la révolution
musique à présent samedi 26 novembre le
coeur du mesnil se produira au temple de
saint quentin en yvelines
les 30 choristes interpréteront une
oeuvre de martin palmeri un compositeur
et chef d'orchestre argentin
une messe qui tient son originalité dans
des rythmes à consonance sud-américaine
et 2 tango
écoutez j'anime prix c'est le bout de sa
présidente elle était au micro de
camille lambert
c'est une oeuvre tout à fait
intéressante je dirais même éclatante
plein d'entrain puissante et parfois
même émouvante elle reprend toute la
liturgie est normal d'une messe mais
encore une fois dans un cadre tout à
fait originale nous allons être
accompagnés par un orchestre composé
d'un quatuor à cordes une contrebasse un
bandonéon bien entendu le piano
et puis tout cela donne un caractère
évidemment tout à fait intéressant
incertain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans ce magazine on parle souvent
d'artistes professionnels mais les
yvelines regorge de talents amateurs à
versailles une troupe de comédiens été
lancé il ya tout juste deux ans elle
joue sur plusieurs scènes d'île de
france et participe au moins molière
regardez dans un peu moins de deux
semaines ils seront sur scène comme
chaque mardi les comédiens de la troupe
en chantier répète la jeune compagnie
est lancée en 2014
son créateur c'est lui pierre henry
gates j'avais une pièce qui était dans
un tiroir depuis quelques années ils
s'appellent les fantômes de l'écrivain
je n'avais pas de projet avec pour la
montée en fait et c'est quand j'ai donné
des cours de théâtre à la compagnie
versailles soleil j'avais un vivier de
deux comédiens dans ses cours là ça
m'est venu d'un coup j'ai envoyé des
mails en disant voilà si je reprends la
pièce cet été est clair écrit est ce que
ça vous intéresse delajoux et qu'on
monte une troupe serait plus sous forme
de coups etc
je ne suis pas lassé petite réaction par
rapport à ok
on prend du début pour relancer deux ans
plus tard ils sont quatorze comédiens
amateurs et jouent des créations de la
comédie dramatique de l'humour noir
deux pièces sorties de l'imagination du
metteur en scène je préfère monter mes
propres projets parce que j'ai ma
conception
j'ai pas me demander quelles sont les
intentions de l'auteur puisque ben voilà
c'est moi du coup voilà si je n'étais
d'une molière ou shakespeare
j'aurai plus de mal à défendre les
propos de l'auteur je pense qu'il m'a
beaucoup plu c'est effectivement de
participer à une pièce qui était une
création et je trouve que c'est toujours
intéressant de s'impliquer dans une dans
une création parce que on donne
naissance un personnage une jeune troupe
qui a déjà joué à deux reprises lors du
mois molière et qui parcourt les scènes
villes de france
[Musique]
on part maintenant à elancourt est plus
aisé exactement au ciné cette sont
directeurs l'ubo quand nous donne son
coup de coeur regardez alors le coup de
coeur du ciné cette semaine c'est le
très beau film franco iranien qui
s'appelle le client alors je prends ma
fiche pour pas écorché le nom du
réalisateur parce que c'est un mirage
lien il s'appelle asghar farhadi à
l'iranienne 44 ont extrêmement
talentueux d'ailleurs ce film a obtenu
deux prix juste plus au festival de
cannes le prix du scénario c'est un
désaccord qui est très connu pour la
qualité de ses scénarios et le prix
d'interprétation masculine pour un
monsieur qui s'appelle saab hausse et me
voilà mon sac raconte l'histoire d'un
couple qui doit qui est obligés de
déménager et qui va louer un nouvel
appartement et un incident lié à
l'ancien propriétaire va bouleverser
leur existence je vous en dis pas plus
asghar farhadi sait le spécialiste on va
dire de l'introspection du couple c'est
un film qui parle de la difficulté des
rapports entre hommes et femmes des
difficultés les rapports humains
c'est à la limite du thriller par
moments et c'est vraiment un très beau
film qui vient donc après les deux
autres film d'asghar farhadi qui sont
très connus comme le passé et séparation
et qui venez le découvrir en version
originale dans nos salles
tchekhov
[Musique]
rien rater la joie
je m'en servais machine the passenger
[Musique]
mieux la mer
comme chaque semaine avant de nous
quitter plusieurs rendez vous culturel à
surtout ne pas manquer à maurepas
l'espace albert camus expose jusqu'au 30
novembre des pastels c'est la première
édition du salon régional de cette
technique picturale 45 artistes
franciliens et 130 tableaux vous
attendent à partir du 29 novembre le
château de versailles propose une
nouvelle exposition faite et
divertissement à la cour à cette
occasion l'opéra royal se mettent aussi
à la fête
le centre de musique baroque de
versailles a réalisé un pastiche d'opéra
composé par le pour louis xiv louis 15
louis saez c'est à découvrir jeudi 24
novembre à 20 heures
maintenant un rendez vous pour les plus
petits 3 conte magique et mystérieuse
sont à découvrir
ça se passe à magny les hameaux à
l'estaminet et la maison de
l'environnement
plusieurs créneaux et horaires sont
proposés toutes les informations sont à
retrouver sur le site de la commune
après blanche neige dans les jardins de
l'orangerie c'est au tour de l'opéra
royal de recevoir angelin prejlocaj le
chorégraphe aixois présente cette fois
sa dernière création la fresque regardez
cet extrait
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour les amateurs de jazz direction
le prisme la salle élan courtoise
accueille laurent mignard et le duke
orchestra 15 musiciens et laurent
mignard prennent les célèbres les titres
du célèbre jazzman duke ellington
regardez un extrait
[Musique]
le cetud culture est maintenant terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis
les programmes continus sur tv fil 78 et
moi je vous dis à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]